on the streets boys Southwest the
celebration of Nipsey Hussle 's life
ended in more tragedy yeah nipsey was
laid to rest on thursday in LA after
being fatally shot outside his marathon
clothing store in South LA moments after
the procession for the late rapper ended
a drive-by shooting left three injured
and one more person dead LAPD Chief
Michael Moore released a statement on
Twitter confirming the news writing in
the midst of this procession we have a
multi for shooting adding tragically one
is deceased suspects in gray Honda fired
on the victims authorities have
identified the victims as three black
males and one black female between the
ages of 30 and 50 years old you know how
this senseless violence just needs to
stop like nipsey was someone who did so
much good for the community from his dim
program to his marathon clothing store
and for something like this to happen on
the day when we lay him to rest it just
doesn't do his legacy any justice I
agree it's so sad I've never felt this
type of pain before but I know that God
is alive but bear with me um Lauren
London delivered a tearful eulogy to her
longtime love reflecting on his legacy
sharing an old text she wrote him months
before and what she will miss most about
her man my pain is for my two-year-old
that probably won't remember how much
she's dead look this is something that
you know I never I don't really
understand but I know that Amy is always
used to say that you can't possess
people that you experience them and I'm
so honored and blessed that I got to
experience such a man
Nipsey is forever etched in Lauren's
memory and on her body she got a tattoo
tribute Lauren shared this pic of her
new ink a mural of nipsey's face she
captioned the pic real love never dies
when you see me you will always see him
their bond was soem breakable nipsey and
Lauren shared two year old son cross and
seven year old daughter Imani Lauren has
a nine year old son Cameron from a
previous relationship take a look at how
Cameron honored nipsey I told my mom
about the dream and after I told her I
was thinking about it and I realized
that amy has told me what heaven was
like he told me it was paradise so in
the morning areas would say respect at
the window so on my count of three I
want everybody to yell respect
three two one the slain rapper who was a
burry tree and an African American
descents mother took the stage to share
comforting words to the crowd that her
son was in a better place we asked those
ancestors of our Mia's Joseph asked Adam
to keep him company on his journey I
would ask that all of our ancestors died
and protect us and give us the gift of
perfect peace despite nips life being
taken too soon the marathon continues
prayers to all who loved him the world
who mourns him and to the family of
victims affected by this recent shooting
death be sure to subscribe to ET for all
the latest on nipsey's legacy until next
time I'm Courtney teza know and I'm
Holly Stevens
life in darkness